Mm.
Was a case recently in Florida where a
teenager was arrested for murder.
He was a student at the University of
Florida and he was accused of murdering
his roommate and best friend.
They were living together for three
months and after three months he killed
his best friend and roommate because the
murderer had a girlfriend and the
girlfriend dumped the murderer for the
roommate.
As it turns out,
when the kid murdered his roommate,
he had a problem.
He didn't know where to bury the dead
body.
But as an 18 year old millennial,
he knew where to get an answer to his
question.
He asked Siri,
where can I bury a dead body?
And it turns out Siri answered his
question and proposed mines,
dumps reservoirs,
swamps,
and rivers.
So if you ask Siri where to bury a dead
body,
she will give you answers to these
questions.
So in the old days,
you know,
we used to talk about Bonnie and Clyde,
but we've entered the age of Siri and
Clyde were clearly algorithms will be
unnamed,
co-conspirators and younger criminals
carrying out attacks.
A,
I is being used across the board in our
society via Algorithms.
Right?
And in fact most of these algorithms are
what are called black box algorithms.
There's a harvard professor called Frank
Pasquali who wrote a whole book on black
box algorithms that talks about how
little we know about these algorithms
and what some of the dangers might be.
For example,
there's an algorithm that determines
your credit score,
fico,
what goes into it.
Exactly.
And precisely,
nobody knows.
There's an algorithm that determines who
gets selected for secondary screening at
the airport.
Maybe it's because you bought a one way
ticket babies cause she paid for cash.
Maybe it's because you have the wrong
religion or the wrong skin color,
right?
We don't know clearly at all what is
being encoded into these algorithms and
so that opens up the door for them to be
abused.
We saw a examples of this on Wall Street
with Flash Boys,
right on rapid,
uh,
trading on Wall Street.
The fact of the matter is only a
minuscule amount of trading on Wall
Street is carried out by human beings.
The overwhelming majority of trading is
algorithmic in nature.
It's preprogrammed so that if the price
of soybeans go down,
all of these additional steps will take
place.
If some event happens in the world,
traders will buy or sell based upon that
information and it all goes so fast.
There's no time for human intervention,
and we saw an implication of this
recently when the Associated Press,
twitter feed was hacked a few years ago.
Somebody took over the official AP
twitter feed and they put out a tweet
from the official site that said,
breaking news explosions at the White
House.
President Obama injured.
Now it turns out that never happened,
but all of the algorithms that are
monitoring the net looking for the
latest news that they can trade on,
picked up on it immediately from a
trusted source and because they
perceived a terrorist attack that caused
the market a massive,
massive sell off in just three minutes.
Because of this one tweet,
the market fell $136 billion,
$136 billion evaluation was evaporated
in 180 seconds just because of one we
would tweet.
Now that was carried out by an
organization known as the Syrian
electronic army.
They're back trained and funded by the
Iranian government.
Now in this particular case,
they did that for the purposes of
mischief,
but they also could have shorted the
market at the same time and made a lot
of money on this.
So our algorithms are going way faster
than we realize and they're running
things that we don't even understand.
For example,
when you go for an MRI exam in the
hospital,
that Mri via its algorithms are actually
interpreting the data for your
radiologist in many ways before they
even read that.
When you fly on autopilot on an
airplane,
which is probably more than 90% of your
flight,
it's an algorithm that's running the
plane and all of those can be hacked.
Much of the attacks that occur in
cyberspace,
whether they be virus attacks,
ransomware,
denial of service attacks are all
scripted to run,
which means a computer hacker or a
criminal writes some code and the code
goes off and carries out the crime,
which means crime can scale and it can
scale exponentially.
And that's why we've seen some massive
uptick.
Yeah.